bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you we have an exciting
show for you today you see the tie was
the tire what's he doing with the Titan
I've had a time we ever talked about the
tie and we're gonna be talking about
Islam submission to who to your neff's
to your desires to a man to woman to a
monkey note to the one who created you
but some people have come to that state
they've acknowledged that there is a
crater there is a purpose why I'm here
in this life but now they want to try to
form an agreement with the one who
created them and say you know i'll
submit to you but you're going to let me
still drink i'll submit to you and you
can still let me have my girlfriend no
it doesn't work like that and to cover
this very venus is a very important
topic because you want to be successful
in life in this life and the life to
come you know there's going to be a day
of judgment you going to be judged and
then there's two places to go the
delights of paradise or the hill fire we
want to stay away from that so let's
bring out my next guest to cover this
topic my brother and your brother kemmel
i'll come on out my brother so I'm like
oh have a seat you're here on the game
show the deed show
I love there's only one word is his
messenger Allah like him
o Allah there's only one bed Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that may be
it may be is it the victory salamo
alaikum like so no he's brought to you
mr. Dante's bounty thank you for being
on the Dean show my pleasure to be on
the beam show this is exciting to have
you here thank you very much now I heard
something or you heard me say something
from back there I mentioned something I
tight I've never worn a time to show and
now there's some might be somebody who's
like man Eddie sold out what's happening
man he's imitating the so-and-so so can
you tell us clear this up is there is
because we want to talk about something
that's so important to us and this is
very important also so let's just clear
this up is this is this permissible
Islam to wear time ok yes first of all
yes it is permissible yeah ok so I want
to get in trouble with anybody well
hopefully I want to do this the right
way we want to do this show and we want
to do everything dress right look right
and we want to talk right and and you
look great if I'm in sha Allah except
well you know there's nothing wrong with
the tie yeah and initially it were
historically the tie had another piece
to it that made it look like a cross so
basically your shirt had two extra
buttons here and then you had the
material similar to that of your ties
same design same pattern and you would
basically button this other piece across
and then when you put the tie on it
looked like you were wearing a cross so
because of that some kind of hatred and
issues developed in the hearts of
Muslims specifically for the for the tie
but obviously it's no longer that and
and so it scholars say that there is
nothing wrong with wearing the tie
because it's become a common you know
piece of clothing it's not anything that
would single you specifically to be
belonging to a specific like creed or
religion because everybody wears the tie
you know so so there's nothing wrong
with it as long as you you're not doing
it for the sake of imitation we're just
wearing a normal garment and it's not
made of pure natural silk or there's
nothing
with it but what about imitation now now
where some people say you're imitating a
certain people were you really going to
say about them well the the scholars
have spoken about that and they said
that you know imitating where it's / not
permissible is where you wear something
that signifies you belong to the
specific belief system or specific creed
so wearing the yarmulke for example you
would make you would make most people
think that you're a Jewish person or
where that that color with I don't know
what they call it that color the
priestly color with a with a white part
in there would make you look like you're
a priest or you know something like that
but or wearing a cross would make you
specifically look like you belong to a
certain belief or creed but wearing the
suit and tie a few words if you see
someone in a suit and tie even the
Muslim and you don't think I use this
man Muslim or non-muslim it doesn't it
doesn't necessarily represent any belief
system or religion yeah and for that
reason the scholars say it's permissible
you'd have to take off just the whole
suit then I mean that just yeah because
you sometimes you were and I also wear a
lot of suits and ties and I love wearing
the suit and tie and a lot of times
people will meet me and they'll say take
off the tie because then you resembling
non-muslims well what about the rest of
the outfit you know then the shirt the
pants the the jacket vest and everything
else so you just have to remove
everything but because it doesn't
specifically mean you belong to any
certain beliefs or anything like that it
there's no issue with it in shuttle is
this is what the scholars have said okay
so now you guys can continue Eddie's
Eddie and he hasn't sold out to Freddie
and everything's all good and study so
here we're all right so let's go on to
the topic we need to submit and we need
to do it how the crater wants us to do
it but there's some people that now they
want to submit which is something
natural to submit to the one who created
you and due to the beautiful things that
he's called you to do and then get that
beautiful thing that money can't buy
peace yeah but now some people want to
barter now they want to start playing
games talk to us see first of all you
look at Islam and Islam comes from the
root is to slam which means to submit
and it's funny that you you want to
enter the religion of submitting but you
don't want to submit a hundred percent
that's why people laugh at the oxymoron
or
of saying I'm a non practicing Muslim
because the Muslim is one who submits to
his creator so if you're a non
practicing Muslim that means your non
submitting submitter AHA really doesn't
make much sense not because we're
supposed to submit a hundred percent
we're supposed to submit to Allah and
when Allah says go right you go right he
says go left you go left because that's
the attribute of someone who has
submitted to the Creator no just like if
you have a student who doesn't listen to
a single word the teacher says teacher
can't describe him as being a submissive
student or an orator a child you know if
you if you have a child who doesn't
listen to you can't say well he's very
submissive so when you submit to Allah
you do what he tells you to do because
he is the creator and you are the
servant or you are the slave if you want
to be more specific even see so a lot of
times you'll find people they and and we
meet sometimes non-muslims in the street
and they want to become Muslim but they
have stipulations so they'll say
something like and i'll become muslim
but i don't want to stop drinking
alcohol or I'll become Muslim but I love
my pork chops so I'll be a Muslim but
I'll still eat pork or they'll tell you
things like you know I want to keep
doing whatever it is that they want to
keep doing because the heart is attached
to it sometimes there's one person who
made so many stipulations and then he
said i'll become muslim i had just had
to ask and look you're forgetting that
islam is about submission you had a lot
of these are situations huh absolutely
and we're going to get to the month yeah
the Muslims as well yeah some Muslims
have submission issues as well but some
non Muslims would say you know they
would have so many stipulations and then
say I will submit if I can do all these
things and they turn look this is the
religion of submitting to Allah but you
have conditions and you want to submit
only if this happens or only if that
happens and and that's not really some
coming into Islam not really submitting
because I always ask people who is the
Lord and who's a servant yeah you're
trying to put set down the rules of your
own religion now and yet claimed that
you're submitting to Allah is over to
you would I mean just interesting if I
can interject I mean if you had a boss
at work and you know big corporate
company and now you're not going to go
and sit there and you know give them all
tomatoes and Salman you know change the
rules and work for your company but you
know you know I have to be able to leave
at this time and I can do that take this
any time off that I want to say you know
what go we'll get someone else or to
please pull you over and say you know
what I'll Drive
this road if you can make it 60 instead
of 40 or and you don't have that choice
you know with many things in life but
people are okay with submitting there
until you actually met this guy one time
and and he claimed to have an issue with
submitting so you think that he's
probably a very stubborn guy who doesn't
submit to any authority or anything on
earth so he started telling me i don't i
have a problem with submitting to
anything or anyone so I immediately told
him but you do submit you submit every
single day to so many things and he
immediately realize it that he submits
to the traffic laws he stops at the
traffic light he does this he drives at
the speed limit you know he doesn't do
what's illegal he has to do we know
certain things to stay out of trouble so
then he is a minute that's submitting he
is submitted so I told him but you do
submit and he immediately realized he
said yes you are could I be the word
people aren't used to you hearing this
word submit that's true and because you
know this exaggerated thing of freedom
you're free to do as you please as long
as you don't step on the toes of the
majority which isn't really true because
when you look at society you'll find so
many do's and don'ts in it that you're
not really free and that's why you know
a lot of Muslim scholars and
philosophers they argue that there is no
such thing as absolute freedom let's
stop here so there's no such thing as
absolute freedom and we're going to take
a break and be right back on a deshawn
excellent no speech is better than to do
that would call people to Allah and to
do there were no speech is better no
nothing is better than that is it true
that if one person I'm the Allah giving
you an ability to guide so much for the
lost permission the creator's permission
that was better than everything in this
world but in the whole world and
everything that's in it in another
narration it's better than the best of
wealth but if we really felt that Eddie
would we not be getting out getting down
and this is something that we encourage
all the MSAs all the dowel organizations
the mustards to get this we want to
print more we give these to the
Nautilus's for free for free for free we
want our brothers it
we're back with my brother your brother
Shaikh came out Melky on the Dean show
you're really not free you think you're
free talk to us that's where we left off
yeah you can't find anyone on earth who
is a hundred percent free and has no
restrictions no limitations doesn't have
to follow any law or anything I mean
there's no such thing as absolute
freedom is what people tell you there's
no such thing and so everything you know
it comes with its price and even if you
want to imagine some guy out there in
the wilderness who has no laws and not
he's still bound and he's still a slave
it might be that he's a slave to his own
desires and some people are slaves to
their own desires they follow their
desires so much that they can't break
away from that they're just pulled in so
they're even not free when they pursue
their desires to the max they're still
not free hold a hold of free there's
some song back from job free to do what
i want free what there's so many of
these songs and so every commercials
talking about how we love freedom and
that's why you have you know you get
free men so what are you talking about
now they're like what are you talking
about we got songs about freedom this
debt I'll tell you something alright so
I grew up around the world right and
before coming to the states immediately
before coming to the States I was in
Africa and it's funny that when when I
came from Africa to the States people
would always tell me but you definitely
enjoy your freedom more here right like
what are you talking about all right no
one assigned any number to me when I was
in Africa nobody took anything from my
paycheck nobody told me where I could
park no one told me how fast I could
drive nobody told me how to do anything
it's a mess there so if you want to
argue even though it is a mess if you
want to argue though but it was more
free there than here but of course I
mean I'm not saying let's not have a
structured society what I'm saying is
that you know people if you're told that
you're free enough times as many as many
like of your liberties as they take away
as long as you're being reminded that
you're free you may not notice that
you're not as free as you think you are
you know so so n is the idea is that
nobody is totally free uh-huh and
absolutely and a hundred percent free
everybody submits to one thing or
another whether it be their desires
whether it be man-made laws whether it
be a
or any kind of entity so we always argue
people that if that's the case then you
might as well submit to your Creator if
you're submitting anyways submit in the
right place put in the right place and
you get some rewards out of that you get
to paradise as a result of that cuz
you're eventually gonna die and yeah and
you're gonna submit to the wrong place
anyways you just change that submission
switch it over directly to the right
place yeah because everybody submits to
one thing or another so now we're
talking about that submission to the
like you said the right place to your
Creator but people realizing
acknowledging because Islam is rational
is practical all the proofs and
evidences are there it's not blind faith
absolutely it backs up everything that
you need with clear authentic evidence
but even people they realize this but
again back to what you were saying they
want to continue doing things their way
right and and actually in the Quran in
surah al-baqarah in the second chapter
of the Quran Allah surgeon says yeah you
had Lavina a minus the Holy Office in me
casa o you who believe enter into
totality meaning enter a hundred percent
into Islam not ninety percent not ninety
five percent not ninety eight percent
but enter one hundred percent into Islam
but like we were saying you know people
they have issues with submitting it
could be that their desire you know is
pulling them in a different direction so
they don't want to submit to Allah
whatever it is something that they love
of this worldly life too much and the
example as I always say even with
Muslims you'll find Muslims will have
submission problems like I said that
someone who who smokes when he stole
that it's prohibited in Islam is not
allowed to smoke they try to argue
against that they say no it's just
disliked it's not it's not you know
prohibited yeah to smoke because what
he's attached to you know he's attached
to his nicotine into his cigarettes so
he wants to argue there because there's
the attachment somebody else you tell
them you know it's not permissible for
you to to use usury or get a mortgage
through a certain system that's not
permissible but they badly want a home
so they start to argue with you and
someone else or a woman for example her
sister doesn't wear hijab she has no
problem submitting when she hears that
smoking is haram were prohibited but
then when she hears about a job then she
start
going into you know excuses but well we
live in this country and if I wear hijab
it might be assaulted in the street so
therefore it's probably better for me to
not wear hijab these are all submission
problems and alessa's submit one hundred
percent no excuses so what do we do now
what do we I mean is this a dangerous
thing now is this something that can be
fixed how do we fix it well yes it is
dangerous and it can be fixed of course
and this is and I like what you said
earlier because Islam is rational and
it's reasonable and Allah will never
command you to do something that's an
impossibility that's all one of the
definitions of of the halal that I like
is what Allah permits but also agrees
with you you know it goes with your
nature yeah it goes with your nature so
Allah is not going to command you to do
something that just totally goes against
human nature and you find it yeah it's
not like something like a weight that
you can't live like someone say lick 500
pounds and you can't do it something
that the weight that you can lift and
very few people can lift 500 pounds just
me and a few other guys so so the thing
is that you know we're in the day and
age where a lot of people they want they
they don't want to submit a hundred
percent and we we have something that
the Muslims do they do photoshopping you
know when you know they find out that
this is not permissible in Islam they
keep looking all over the place the
other physically drive to other Imams
and mosque until they find someone who
tells them it's ok or they go online and
they do photo shopping online and then
they just add the federal to the basket
now we're playing I mean this is serious
now yes this is you're playing games
with the with the Dean I'll tell you
that it's gotten to the point where some
people pray istikhara me which is them
how do you translate it's too hot into
English this is like the prayer of
guidance yeah I how about I invent the
term decisional prayers as you know
prayer that's not fancy enough yeah all
right so you pray for a lot to guide you
should i do this or should I not do this
some people actually praised the Hara
and to see if they can do something
that's hard on you know like they want
to buy a house through prohibited ways
and they'll praise the heart of the sea
should I sign the mortgage or not that's
like basically putting some alcohol on
the table and then praying to rock art
and saying okay
help me if drinking this alcohol is good
for me then make it possible and it's
right there you know if you don't you
don't make that prayer about something
that you know is clearly haram you know
but it's it's that that's what's
happening now people are so pulled and
drawn they don't want to submit one
hundred percent and so they have all
these colorful excuses for not following
and submitting to Allah commands us to
do in the Quran tell us how do we
balance it out because it is I mean we
know that if this Dean would have came
upon a mountain that mountain would
crumble this is correct excellent but
now you know for the new Muslims who are
coming into it we're going to do it and
even Muslims who are starting to turn
their life around and now they look at
this as just a lot of rules and
sometimes it can be just overbearing how
do we balance it out where they know
that this is out of a loss love that he
loves us he wants what's best for us so
how do we balance it out where we don't
play the games and we strive to submit
to everything that the crater nice wants
it and let me work off of answering that
question from the verse that you just
mentioned where allah subhana allah says
in our laminate alice tomorrow
abdul-jabbar for a banana I mean how was
[ __ ] amina so alas saying that we we
offered this like this responsibility
with this trust to the the heavens the
mountains the earth and they refused it
and then human beings they took this
responsibility of themselves this test
of life being tested in this life been
Allah says vahamil in Sun in no kin of
alumina hula the human being accepted it
and his nature that he is the Loom that
he is unjust and ahold that he is
ignorant and the scholars say that every
problem on earth can be traced back to
these two sources ignorance and
following your desires either ignorant
or your onion just because you follow
your desire you know that this is
justice but you want to do something
that's unjust because you get some kind
of benefit for and you follow your
desire so every problem and if you
contemplate every problem on the planet
it goes back to ignorance or it goes
back to just someone being oppressive
because they're following their desires
look at wars look at things that are
happening around this you find this
our total ignorance define to us so
someone might know if they don't already
when we say following your desires what
does that mean it means basically that
you you follow whatever your you would
like to do for example you know that
let's just make a simple example that
doing a specific deed is not permissible
you know but you have the desire to do
it you know that Allah said don't do it
but you have that desire to do it and so
now you follow your desire in doing it
even if it means let's say for example
someone might you know take the money of
the orphan or take the money from you
know a business partner and rub him and
be oppressive in that sense why because
he's following his desire his lust his
love for money so so in that sense all
problems can be traced to one of those
two things now it's one of the ways to
to kind of understand submission as far
as it comes it's related to the commands
of allah saw said is that you know you
find out when allah commands us to do
something you when you examine it you
either find that it's a hundred percent
good or one hundred percent bad if he
tells us to stay away from it or a
mixture of the two so just very quickly
when you look at for example worshipping
allah alone and not attributing any
partner to him right this is a hundred
percent good there's not one percent of
evil in that yeah so when Allah calls us
to what we call toe hate worship
worshiping him alone we look at it we
see that it's a hundred percent good
then a low awarness of worshiping things
along with Allah which is known as [ __ ]
and Islam so you don't worship anything
with Allah we don't know and worship
anything besides Allah that's like
worshiping the Sun the Moon a man
prophet an angel it could be a prophet
and angel it could be someone really a
saint a good person i worthy of worship
yeah so now when you look at worshiping
things besides allah you see that it's a
hundred percent evil and that's why it's
so clear to us when we should stay away
from it but then there are things in
life to have a mixture of good and bad
in them yeah and these things when you
look at them and you see which one
outweighs the other you can understand
why allah mated hollow or hard on
permissible or lawful for example
alcohol you know when Alice doesn't want
that about wine in the Quran that
there's good and bad in it but the bad
outweighs the good and that's why we can
clearly understand why Allah told us to
stay away from consuming alcohol because
all the problems it causes in society
from accidents from destroying homes
from destroying people's wealth from
getting people to do all other kinds of
sins so we can see clearly why Allah
toes to stay away from from alcohol or
from you know wine or whatever
intoxicant specifically yeah so then it
makes sense to us and it's not that hard
for us to submit but now there's
sometimes issues where you cannot find
the exact reason not the exact reason
sorry the exact wisdom as to why Allah
forbade it I'll give you one example you
know when people go and make it all off
around the Kaaba when they
circumambulate the sacred house in Mecca
they make toe off counterclockwise so
why not clockwise I mean obviously the
reason we do it is that that's how it
was taught to us by the process of
settling that's the reason but what's
the wisdom for going counterclockwise
around the Kaaba and not clockwise
around it and you ask this question to
people most people don't know how to
answer because really there isn't a
clear answer some people have said that
well the heart is actually on the left
side actually the heart is not on the
left side it's in the middle the loudest
part is thumping on the lettin it can be
heard on the left so but suppose the
heart was on my right shoulder can I
make a left turn what does that have to
do with it so suppose the heart is on
the left is that why we make you
circumambulate counterclockwise alright
some other people said well the earth is
spinning counterclockwise that's where
we will make the last counterclockwise
what that could be a wisdom somehow but
suppose the earth spun clockwise I can't
make a counter clockwise turn so you see
with this issue we don't know exactly
all the wisdoms why we go that way but
we submit you have to know when to put
your reasoning logic on hold what no in
this place and actually I'm coming to
that because a lot of people think that
there's a conflict between your
intellect or there could be a conflict
between your intellect and what islam
teaches and they could never be because
your intellect good intellect will
always agree
with what Allah commands but opinion can
disagree with what Allah commands that's
why you find some people they put their
opinion in front of the commands of
Allah and they are and they make
mistakes and guess who is the first
person to do that the double a bliss his
first one to do that was a bliss because
he was told he was given the command and
he put his opinion in front of what
Allah commanded him to do he start to
say I'm better than him you know he's
created from clay I'm great opinion
Meyer exactly so we see prevalent today
exactly and and be and so your intellect
will always agree with the Quran sound
intellect will agree with this slap your
opinion can disagree because you follow
your desire let's take a break and we'll
be right back how come from a science
major when you look at the Bible says
the earth has four corners the is that's
wrong if any Christian can point out a
single anachronistic a single
unambiguous treatment where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him says say that I am God
or ye worship me a matrix of
Christianity
welcome back to the Dean show okay my
brother so continuing on now the thing
is we want to use our reasoning our
logic the tools that the Creator has
given us to find out what the truth is
right right but at what point do we say
okay now we have discovered we've been
blessed that ok Islam is the way of life
from the crater at what point do you now
put the revelation before your reasoning
and balance things out yes I what I'm
saying okay well first I would like to
assuage any fear is that a non-muslim
might have that you have to blindly do
things in Islam and this is a great
thing about Islam is that everything you
the wisdoms are explained as to why you
do or don't do something there's a logic
there's nothing that's just irrational
that you have to do out of the blue or
that you told you know to roll around in
the dirt because there's some kind of
blessing you'll get from there is
nothing like that and and also will take
this opportunity to explain that you
know in some religions when they use the
word faith it's totally different than
how Muslims use the word faith faith it
just means this kind of blind belief
just like closing your eyes and just
jumping in that people will tell you you
have to have faith in God I don't have
proof i don't know anything but i just
have something called fate which is
basically almost like this blind belief
in Islam Allah asked I caused us to
contemplate his creation to contemplate
his book the Quran itself to really
contemplate and look at it that if it
was from other than Allah it would have
you no flaws discrepancies
contradictions in it so this is
something of me personally I love that
Allah tells us to think to look to
contemplate we were never taught oh shut
off your intelligence and just that's
why one time one of my professors my
biology professor we're talking about
religion and she said that I have to I
have like their to me like there's one
me the scientific me and then there's
the religious me and of course this is a
very this is a very bad thing to admit
to so I immediately came in with will in
Islam you don't have to separate your
religious self from your scientific cell
because we don't have that conflict in
Islam yeah you know you never you know
were told to do something and it goes
against logic and it goes against
studies and it goes against you know
rational or rational thought and that's
why you know that this is a great
comfort for Muslims that you don't have
to have the scientific you and then the
religious you and so I shut it off then
and then now okay now science has gone
on my years of you see that we're not
the typical lot of the people that
practice some some some religions are
and it's a it's problematic for them
yeah you know because if I understand
science and logic and I'm smart then I
have to shut it off just so I could
believe in my religion that means that
religion requires no no logic no
thinking no rationale it's not a good as
Muslims we don't have to do that we
never have that problem this is the
great thing but I actually wanted to go
over real quickly how we can convince
someone when it comes to simple issues
and like I said we encounter this a lot
when someone will say you know I'll
become a Muslim but I want to keep
drinking yeah or I love my my beer we're
actually some people will tell us things
like I I want to become Muslim but I
love pork chops too much you know and
sometimes we we make them realize what
they're saying because really what
they're saying it's something very
shameful you know so we actually make
them aware of what they're saying and
this is something we actually do we'll
talk to someone else on this look so
someone will say look I really love my
pork chops that's the only reason I
can't become Muslim so you believe that
there's one God one creator yes the
prophet saw said let mrs. Perez prophet
and his messenger yes you're okay with
the five pillars and everything else he
absolutely the only thing stopping is
that you love pork chops too much yes
actually guilt them out of it because
it's very shameful which I'm listen so
Allah is the one who gives you
everything that you have your health
your intelligence your you're the
provision that work the job that you
have your family your loved ones think
things that you cannot put a price on
your eyesight you know you're hearing
your all these things and every minute
and every day he is keeping you in good
health how many days you could have
woken up sick how many potential actions
could you have had and none of that
happens to you and then he gives you up
so many kinds of juice that you can
drink so many kinds of meat you know you
can eat all kinds of things from the sea
seafood all kinds of fish all kinds of
birds and you've got cows and
and go to you got all these things and
he's giving you so many different kinds
of blessings and fruits and vegetables
and the human being can go without
drinking for three days and without
eating for 32 41 days and you need it
you can go through so much and survived
so much you know physically and you're
telling me that this Great Creator who
provides so much for me I won't enter
his religion I won't submit to him
because I love pork and you know when we
do that they but but at this point
they're looking at the ground they look
of course of course I can leave for okay
there's so many other things yeah okay
let's do this let's become mostly huh so
it works very well for us in hamdullah
we're gonna have to cut out so little
time we have so much to cover we're
going to have to ensure law have you
back again so closing comments and
advice for those who are going through
some of these things that we just
tackled in this show well you're not
alone and every problem in every
obstacle that you encounter someone else
went through it and a lot of times when
someone would say I can't leave pork I
would bring them my brother-in-law and
say look he said his problem was he
couldn't become Muslim because of pork
then we asked him right in front of
person he went through the same issue
his pork an issue now like I never think
about pork every problem you're going
through someone went through it before
and they overcame it because Allah will
never ask for you to cross to jump over
a mountain or an instrument surmountable
like obstacle so everything that you're
going through someone went through it
and they made it over that obstacle and
you will yourself in Charlotte thank you
very much I blow the crater happens
earth reward you for being with us
exactly where we are I hope you got the
benefit I surely did and all those who
are sincerely humbly trying to learn the
truth this should go down easy and we
would love to have you back with us
again here on the Dean show same time
same channels check the showtimes at the
Dean show calm to sin see when we air on
the TV and also you can view all of our
shows at the Dean show calm we have some
good news for those of you who aren't
able to watch some of the videos and you
love travelling your car you have your
iPods we now have the Dean show com blog
and there you can get our shows the Dean
show radio show on the pot
test and you can download it share all
of our shows with the world help your
neighbors understand this beautiful way
of life of peace that piece that you get
when you humbly and sincerely submit now
to your desires as we talked about on
the show but to the one who created you
who's giving you everything and he's
going to give you more and you'll be
successful in this life and hereafter so
those are some of the things that we
have continued to come back and we'll
see you next time inshallah God willing
again here on the Dean show until then
peace be unto you sonic all of the
profits would have been labeled Muslims
because this essential message was the
same message submissions
this is God talking to you how could I
stand behind the pulpit and Sunday
morning and preach a sermon that I knew
was variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity bismillah al hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
back to the Dean show we're going to be
discussing something that now you've
come to realize that there's a purpose
in life and I need to fulfill my purpose
the way my Creator wants me to live my
purpose that's to serve Him to worship
Him to do the most beautiful things as
he told me to do and then paradise
that's the reward but now as we
discussed in the last show this is part
2 to submission what does it mean and
whom I submit to after I agree to submit
to the crater now there's other things
getting in the way so when I come back
we're going to be talking about this
continuing talking about it with brother
che chem amake and you can sing along
with the show you can sing along with
this tune until we come back you and the
family is very simple Allah there's only
Allah there's only one
is His Messenger a la la la
ha there's only one God and Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that may be
it may be a just to break the ice come
on Michael might expand our peace be
unto you I like sit down no Santa thank
you very much for being with us again we
just had to continue talking about
submission the good stuff right the good
stuff ok now let's just go a little in
reverse and talk about to bring people
up to speed people can go back to the
Dean show calm you and she'll law have
your own you're going to have your own
section there that people go on and
watch all the shows that we've done with
you and the first one that we did this
is a part two was about submission right
and just kind of recap what we what we
discuss in last show before we continue
on okay so first of all in in the last
show we spoke about first that Islam
means to submit to Allah which is who is
your Creator so whatever he told you to
do you should do it if he tells you go
right you go right go left to go left
but at the same time he's not going to
ask you to do things that are beyond
your means he's not going to ask you to
do things that don't agree with human
nature or things that are impossibility
things of that sort so it's very
rational very logical what Allah asked
you to do and a lot of times out of his
his mercy and his wisdom he lets us see
the wisdoms behind why he prohibited
something or the wisdom behind why he
made something permissible or commanded
us to do something but like we were
saying a lot of people has submission
issues some people want to become Muslim
but the love you know their alcohol or
love the certain meal or love a certain
act that's prohibited by in Islam so
they'll tell you I'll become Muslim but
then they'll give you the stipulation
stipulations there likewise same thing
for Muslims you know though they're
Muslim they pray they submit where it's
comfortable in the Union and convenient
that's the magic word right there so
it's it's convenient for them to submit
they'll do it but then when it disagrees
that's when they either try to find an
excuse go photoshopping find somebody
who says that it's a lot it doesn't
matter who the person is whether they're
knowledgeable or not just someone
somewhere tell me that this is okay so i
can do it that's not right you not right
at all you know
and and just to throw it in there when
when you let's say someone gives you an
answer to a question and suppose for
some reason you didn't feel comfortable
with that answer and you don't have
enough knowledge to either investigate
it yourself in this case you go to
someone that you trust that you trust
them to be you know pious and to be
knowledgeable and then you ask them and
you get the answer so what that means is
you don't go looking for the person who
will tell you what you want to hear you
know you would just go to someone that
you trust our knowledge and the believe
will tell you the truth this is in the
case where you don't have the knowledge
yourself to weigh the evidence is right
whatever way you look at it you don't
just pick based on your desire and I
want to find someone who says this is
hella now just not to divert too much
but interestingly there have been
historically scholars who have said kind
outrageous kinds of things but they
didn't have the evidence for it so it's
all about the evidence not about who
said what because you'll find in
historically this has happened scholars
who said dog meat is haha yeah right we
don't want to we don't to try that do it
dog meat is hell others have said that
your mother has to wear hijab in front
of you these are opinions but they
didn't have the valid or there were the
strong evidence is behind it right so
the same thing is like we don't just
look around for someone who will say
what I want to hear we look for someone
that we believe will tell you the truth
and has the evidence to support it which
is all under the umbrella of submitting
to Allah you know it's a lot of people
now when they when they hear a command
of Allah or his prophet saw said love
the first thing they try to do is find a
way around it no the first thing try to
do it as much as you can and if not then
there could be a fatwa and an excuse for
you so a person has to be sincere really
wanting to know what the Creator God
Almighty Allah wants them to do yes what
he told the messenger just like at that
time of Jesus Moses Abraham at their
time they were the teachers they were
teaching the people and now we have the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him who
we have to follow not and his teachings
are either with him or go through him
but just follow his instructions exactly
yes so now being sincere and wanting to
know the truth because as you said if
you're trying to look for some different
opinion from this
in that person you find it you something
to match your desires yeah you might
trick the people but you can't trick the
one who knows the heart exactly exactly
so you just try to find an allowance
then you're not really being very
sincere yes so don't don't play games
don't play games you're getting caught
you get car and the beautiful thing is
evidence Islam is all based there's a
basis behind everything we do and
there's evidence we have what are the
criteria is now that we're looking for
basically and and this is what Allah
also tells us that in the Quran that if
you disagree about an issue you return
it to what Allah and His Prophet SAW
seldom have said about the issue and for
Abdul Allah well with a result in condom
too many Bela if you believe in a line
you believe in the last day then you
return it to Allah and took the
prophecies and you see what they say
about the issue you know because if you
want to follow like some someone
somewhere said this is permissible
you're gonna actually can gather a lot
of very very strange things just like I
gave the example with dog meat being
hollowed you know and when wearing hijab
in front of her own son others have said
some really outrageous things but they
didn't have the evidence to support it
so when someone is sincere they look for
the truth when someone is not they just
want some way out of it so your first
effort is to try to apply what Allah
commands us to do or what the prophets
LMK commands us to do and then if you
can't they might find you some kind of
excuse but your first efforts to try it
today there are some people the minute
they hear a command from a lot the first
thing they want to do is find some way
around it before even attempting to do
it just if that's not submission that's
not know let's take a break sure we'll
be right back on Adi show I came from a
science major when you look at the Bible
says the the earth has four corners it
is wrong
the heavens if any Christian can point
out a single an accommodation a single
unambiguous treatment may Jesus Christ
peace be upon him says say that I am God
always worshipped me I'm retraction
Christianity back here in the Dean show
with my brother in your brother shaikh
talk to us now we are talking about what
it is to be a submitter to the one who
created you something beautiful this is
how one gets peace and we know that
people in this way of life the way of
life of all the messengers God sent
messengers and they revealed the same
way of life surrender and submit to the
will of the creator and now God Almighty
we look at people nowadays are slaves
they won't say they are but they're
slaves to the fashion they're a slave to
consumerism to materialism to
nationalism all these different isms and
now when you try to bring up this word
about being a slave to the one who
created you there's like they feel like
it's some stigma attached is but on the
contrary they're already slaves or
something else let's talk about this
what does it mean when we say that being
a slave to the one who created you
excellent we and the word this for that
in Arabic would be a bob has two
meanings one meaning abdus a worshipper
of a la sua jet and at the same time
abdus actually a slave and that's how
the word was used also by the Companions
they would you know Abdul was referred
to as a slave like if someone had a
servant or something and that's why the
problem prohibited them from saying this
is my Abbot because only Allah owns
truly owns people so he taught them to
say this is my boy or my girl so the
thing is that and like you were saying
and I've actually seen some fairly
knowledgeable people when you say the
word slave they cringe a little like
it's a bad thing yeah or like we're not
owned by Allah sewage it but the truth
is Allah owns us we are slaves of Allah
we were owned by Allah subhana tada and
so therefore he tells us what we can and
can't do even if it's with their own
bodies that's why when you look at the
Sharia or Islamic law it goes into great
details of what we
can and can't do with their own bodies
that's why there's restriction for men
or what kind of hair they can remove
what kind of hair they can't remove for
women they're not allowed to shave their
head bald they're not allowed to you
know pluck their eyebrows why because
Allah tells us what we can and can't do
with these bodies or tattoos for me
tattoos forbidden just like you know if
you were to rent a car suppose you know
Eddie you wanted to for once drive a
really really nice sports car right so
you go and you rent a hyundai accent
right and it's black in color so but you
wanted to drive a yellow car for those
two days yeah and i don't know if you
know hyundai accent entirely sports cars
I was a joke that maybe wasn't very good
one the point is can you change the
color of that car for those two days
that you've rented the vehicle maybe
make it green or yellow like you said
could you doesn't have you couldn't
because you don't own the car yeah same
thing with the tattoos you know you
don't own your body and so you can't
color it and disfigure it that's why
you're not allowed to change your face I
mean unless obviously there's a horrible
accident or something but so what we see
a lot of the celebrities with you know
the Botox and you know the the face
stretched out here from about a hundred
different plastic surgeries not these
things that you you cannot do not allow
the plus they look horrible anyway yeah
you destroying yourself mutilating
yourself and that's why you're not
allowed to to commit suicide to kill
yourself because it was written in Islam
absolutely it's not your love it it's
not you if you owned yourself you could
probably kill yourself but you don't own
your this is a good fact we weren't
discussing terrorism and all these thing
but it's a lot of times is you know
there's a stigma stereotype attached to
Islam and they think you know Muslims
you know killing themselves blowing
themselves up you telling me right now
this is prohibited and what we're
talking about is is like someone like
the going gets tough they can't handle
it anymore and then they just you know
they poison themselves shoot themselves
jump out of a window you know like or
but that or someone going into a
pizzeria and killing a thousand innocent
people right exactly this is not
permissible aslam and then and what they
say there's a joke they say the guy was
about to jump off a roof so they called
the priest the priest came to me said on
your mark alright anyways so the point
is let's stick with our topic so we're
saying that you know when your slave of
Allah surgeon Allah owns you so you do
what a lot of power that tells you to do
ya know if he says go right you go right
go left you go left don't do it you
don't do it because he owns you and
that's why it is it's shameful that
allah so cantata not only he owns you
but he also gives you all the blessings
and everything that you have that's good
and at the same time the only way you
respond to a lot is by disobeying him
that's actually very shameful and very
sad and there's no one on the planet
that would give you suppose that's
there's some billionaire and he just
basically just bought you a house then
he gives you a lot of cash to put in the
bank and give you you know pocket money
and spending money then he gives you a
car and what have you and then you use
that money to put an ad in the paper to
to bad-mouth him and to bad-mouth his
business and to say nasty things about
him then it gives you more money than
you put would you create a whole website
just to insult him and make and do you
think he'll keep giving you you probably
stop giving you no doubt no human being
would keep giving you and well I him a
thorough knowledge means we do not like
in Allah to his creation but look how
allah azza yet keeps giving you every
day in every moment and then you use the
blessings he gives you to disobey him
but he keeps giving you four are
non-muslims what you said a lost one
dolla just so they know if somebody's
never heard this word Allah basically a
la is just the name of God in Arabic a
lot of times people when they hear a lot
i think this might be a different God or
something like that but it's actually
the same God the god of Moses as they
say and because God of Abraham and the
god of Jesus or ASA I didn't set up so
when you say Allah basically you're just
talking about god it's the name of God
in Arabic it's not a different God or
anything of that sort and I would like
to add that if you go to an Arab country
and you go to a church there you will
find that they say Allah in their
service and the Arabic Bible says Allah
as well so Allah keeps giving and giving
and giving even though people are
turning away from him they are doing the
most mischievous things against him they
and whenever they sin against a leather
using a blessing given to them by a lot
to disobey Allah you know people who use
their money in ways that are prohibited
the money is a blessing given to them by
Allah and they're using
to anger Allah you know some people use
their eyesight to anger louder their
hearing listen to things that there
shouldn't or they use their tongue in a
way that they shouldn't all these are
blessings from a lot but a lot is so
merciful and he's so generous he's so
giving he keeps giving them even if they
keep disobeying him which is really
something that absolutely fantastic you
know but when you recognize and you link
every good thing that you have in this
life to a la sua jet then you start to
naturally want to submit to Allah kind
of like when the boss at work you know
you link your relationship with this
boss to that paycheck that comes at the
end of every two weeks so when he says
do this you do it even if you don't
agree with it you might complain about
it with the co-workers you know at the
at the water cooler and what have you
but you do what he says even if it's a
ridiculous idea he says we have to do it
you're gonna do it you know because you
link you know something good that comes
to you from this relationship with your
boss that is the paycheck yeah well
enlightened master data which means we
don't like it a lot its creation but
Allah when he keeps giving you every
good that you have things you can't put
a price on but then when he told you go
right you don't go right it's very
shameful you know and and it puts a lot
of people to shame when they recognize
that that's why I'm saying when you tell
someone how many things Allah gave you
to replace this one thing that you
refuse to give up they start to feel a
shame if when they start to try to count
the blessings of Allah you know to look
tell us how do we balance out where it's
between okay again we we talked about
being rational logical something that is
not just blind faith that we follow
Islam the submission of yourself to the
one who created you has all the evidence
that one needs to realize this is the
truth but now someone who is agreeing
with that that I only worship the One
God but now all the other things come
into play establishing the prayer five
times a day we see a lot of non-muslims
that they come to Islam and they do this
most important thing but then a year two
years later they're still not praying
right and they might see this as now
burden now I got to do this five times a
day how do we distinguish where and help
them to understand this is a blessing
that all these things of staying away
from the let's say consumption of
alcohol eating a pork gambling somebody
basic things that these are blessing
these are things that are going to only
better our lives right talk about you
know the if you look at the religious
people worldwide they don't they don't
drive by a nightclub and say I wish I
was misguided so I could just be in
there jumping up and down like a crazy
animal you know they they feel that they
what they have is greater there they
have bliss because what they have is
greater and when you feel the sweetness
of a man which is the time when you
swirl this the the sweetness of
believing in Allah everything else pales
in comparison you know you don't look at
people with piercings and purple hair
cell man I wish I could do that and
people who are doing all kinds of things
that are illegal and selling drugs or
that's so exciting i wish i could live
that lifestyle they never feel that kind
of remorse they feel that allah replaced
them with something better why because
they tasted the sweetness of faith but
when you don't know the sweetness of
faith it's just burped it burdens him to
you prayer is burdensome to you but as
the Prophet asylum used to say he would
say comfort us with the prayer so saying
announced the prayer so can be
comfortable some people they become
discomfort it because they didn't focus
and in the Salah they don't know what
they're saying in prayer so they don't
feel the sweetness in that sense it will
always be a burden as one of the
scholars said he said the Salah it's
really amazing when you try to do it
quickly and get it out of the way it
takes so long and it becomes so
difficult but when you do it slowly and
you focus and you love it it becomes so
easy and i think everybody i think you
know you everyone in the studio and the
people listening at home they've
probably experienced this in Ramadan
when they go to the long prayers when
they're focused and it's a sewer that
they're familiar with they're like which
today the prayer was so short especially
when they don't eat too much right yeah
you eat too much you don't know what the
Imams saying and you're like man when is
this gonna be over it's the same length
of prayer every single day some days it
was so light some days it was so heavy
because you were into it or not into it
you know and so if you if you don't want
to be into you know the the prayer if
you don't want if you want to do
everything you know with half-heartedly
if there's such a word then it's going
to
become burdensome to you you only sweet
taste the sweetness of faith when you
start to enjoy this act of worship which
is a possibility of course not
impossible so we're going to take a
break and we'll be right back amnesia
all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message was the same as submissions this
is God talking to you how can I stand
behind the pulpit on Sunday morning and
preach a sermon that I knew was at
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity back here on the Dean show
Salaam alaikum nice to know all right
now we're talking my submission so
either you're going to submit willingly
and a lot of things you're having to
submit already I mean you you have to
take the call in nature you have to go
to sleeps would you call these forms of
submission and it's not you you have to
follow some kind of law either laws of
nature laws of gravity gravity yeah so
nobody's just totally free the law of
the land yeah absolutely yes what's
wrong with saying you know what people
feel so comforted sometimes and and and
and very excited to say I'm a
law-abiding citizen but what's wrong
with saying or feel like you know i'm on
i'm a person who abides by the law of
God that's the best absolutely isn't it
that's the way to go you know but
there's a problem here now you know we
talked about you're happy and you're
voluntarily submitting to the latest
fashion you don't want to wear hijab but
you'll put on you know the close of the
the latest celebrity what's on the front
cover of the magazine you'll do that and
you'll submit to what they're leaning
you to submit to pulling you to write
their like hypnotizing you and over here
you're having a hard time submitting to
what Allah told you put a job for
instance or you're having a hard time
fasting but now for that tournament or
for that other let's say modeling career
you're fasting to lose weight
absolutely so you're doing other things
five times a day but you're having a
hard time doing the prayer five times it
i'm just giving these examples but so
here you're submitting in one way but to
something that's going to give you
ultimate source and parallel you not why
is this well let me let me start with
the quick story many decades ago when i
was a young man there was uh I got
pulled over by police officer and I
didn't have the appropriate sticker on
my windshield I didn't know which you
know which color and all that stuff but
it struck me that this officer was
really really upset I mean it's not your
job to be upset I mean you job is just
to say you don't have this the right
color sticker the ticket and give me the
ticket and say okay make sure you put
the right one on but he was so angry
that I didn't have the right sticker on
there and I was thinking look at how
immersed he is into this low how much he
believes in it to the fact that he's
offended that I don't have this pink
stick or the green sticker I mean take
it easier but people could get so caught
up in these things but at the same time
perhaps I'm not saying for sure but
perhaps that same man would overlook so
many of the rules and laws of Allah so
is it may get so angry about this little
sticker and it goes back to what we're
saying that if you if you don't submit
to Allah or to the law of Allah you're
submitting to something at some point or
another it could be as ridiculous as you
know the green sticker versus the pink
sticker and you get upset about that so
the truth is you're going to have to
submit and you're gonna have to use
going to submit to something or if you
don't like it's funny that in in the end
you're gonna be brought back to what you
were running away from like in this the
scholars it would say like that if you
know if you don't walk to the masjid
when you hear the call for prayer if you
don't walk to the message you'll be
carried to the masjid it doesn't mean
anyone's going to force you and carry
two the message it means you're gonna
die what are they gonna do they're gonna
wash you and bring you to the messages
and they're going to pray over you so
you don't come and pray they're gonna
pray over you and when they carry you
and bring into that mr. so you're going
to come in there anyways it's inevitable
how about the woman now that doesn't
wanna yeah I mean like you hot you'll
find one time this actually this woman
told me that you know before I put on
her job I was saying over my dead body
don't know that I put this a job on
which a job basically is the veil which
is a piece
of cloth and I told that's the truth I
mean it would be over your dead body you
would die and then they'll cover you
with a piece of cloth then they'll bring
you pray over you and put you in a hole
in the ground this is the reality of the
situation you know I mean in the end
it's linked to you know paradise or the
Hellfire my love for bid which is not
something simple so your obedience it
also has something to push you to
motivate you to obey Allah that's the
thing next question how do you get
motivated how there's something within
is it something some people is a
deficiency in the law now which there's
no way that can be or is it something
within the person that a person has to
adjust their way of thinking they have
to go ahead and fix what's in themselves
so they can get to submitting well it
could be it could be a hundred and one
different things and that's why when you
look at the way a low will like get us
to do something well Allah will motivate
us into action he will do it in many
different ways in the Quran sometimes
you'll tell us the benefit of doing
something sometimes you'll tell us the
harm of leaving it sometimes you'll tell
us the harm of doing it sometimes he'll
tell us the benefit of leaving something
sometimes you'll tell us the reward in
the acura in the next life sometimes who
tells the reward in this slot and
everyone a different one a different one
of these things might strike the right
chord as they say with that person you
know so it's not like there's a specific
formula say well this is how you you
know you you stay away from your desires
this is how you it's not always that
scaring people with the helper is what
will work sometimes you tell them about
paradise and that will motivate them
into action so everyone gets something
different and is motivated by something
different we just have they're signaling
that we're almost out of time if you can
give some advice to those people the
sincere people who are having some
issues with this state of being a true
worshiper a true slave to the one who
created them okay all those i also want
to leave with the thought that you were
to submit to Allah the one who created
you and the one that he commanded you
this to obey as well which is the
Prophet salah salem over 60 times in the
quran allah will command the believers
to obey the Prophet salah salem and
sometimes you even equate obeying the
Prophet to obeying Allah so he'll say my
uterus all fuckered up our Allah whoever
obeys the
moffat he has obeyed Allah so he made
the almost equal in this sense so
everyone has the desire everyone has
what will pull you in this direction or
that direction but we recognize that
we're slaves of Allah zonigen that he
owns as he tells us what to do what we
can't do he's the one who gives us
everything that we have so when he tells
us to do something we try to fight
against our desire fight against
whatever is pulling us and of material
love of this world and obey our Creator
because there is a greater reward coming
far greater than this dunya and that's
something that we should keep in mind
inshallah may we all be there in the
lights I mean of paradise I mean thank
you very much like a la height on my
pleasure that's what we should be
striving for paradise this life is short
what will you live 10 20 30 years from
now you can die at any minute and at the
end you are slave to everything except
who you should have been enslaved to the
one who created you he's asked you to do
something simple to worship Him alone to
serve Him alone and to be good to be the
best human being that you can be to be
in a constant state of development to
being the best human being that you can
be and that's not going to be achieved
by following your desires is going to be
achieved by following your Creator and
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him come back here
every week to the Dean show calm you can
visit us on the new blog section to get
all of our shows also on audio format we
have volume two of the new dvds for Dawa
along with volume one that we encourage
all the different mustards organizations
Dawa affiliations Dawa msas to get these
in bulk and to share this message of
peace Islam submission to the One God
how come from a science major when you
look at the Bible says the the earth has
four corners the it is wrong
even if any Christian can point out a
single an accommodation a single
unambiguous treatment where gvf cash
peace be upon him says say that I am God
or way she worshipped me I'm redress of
Christianity it's called it lay
everybody sleep in I arise and ask a lot
of thinking me Omar you see hola you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my Seng tomorrow I'm you seem for
slave you're my love alone I'm the one
runs away oh look I me